there's been reports of an explosion
outside liverpool street station a huge
explosion
are on the street up in front of me and
all i could see was the top of a bus
completely destroyed i just thought what
if i was dead i heard a very loud bang
the lights went out and the carriage
filled with smoke there's just row after
row of ambulances turning up all the
time we will not allow violence
to change our societies or our values
something like 45 people so far have
died
and the number of injured is approaching
a thousand
and of that
150 of those are said to be seriously
injured i spoke to a police
officer just a little while ago and he
said there were a number of seriously
injured people he used the word busloads
gary thanks for coming on the show and
joining us today
many of us can remember that day on the
7th of july when four bombs hit london
um it's forever printed in our history
but you have a very
unique
experience of that day
can you tell me about what that day was
for you personally
yeah i was actually uh i was on
fraternity leave at the time i was part
of our new newly formed sort of
counterterrorism team
with the british transport police um my
wife phoned me and said have you heard
what's happened on the
on the rail network on the underground
she said they've been a power surge and
i saw a car off and said look i'll find
you back in a minute um and i phoned one
of me mates up i could hear the blues
and two's going he said look we've just
been bombed
get your grab kit and get in
then he went on standby
we've just been bombed again
um and
there was no chance i was going to get
in the network was closing down the
phones were going down
and i just felt at that time a little
bit helpless because
realistically i should have been up at
work
yeah my wife had just had
our third son when i did get back into
work
um it was chaos in
central london as you know
um and one of my bosses just came up and
said to me oh
we need to get you down to the temporary
military
he said because people are falling over
it's just horrific
and also i will
wire me
he said oh you're a neck squaddy you'll
be right
we obviously had to deal with the 52
victims um
countless body parts
um and what was left of the bombers um
and it
it was um it was an unpleasant task we
was actually um receiving the deceased
at the temporary military
so as they could
be processed and hopefully identified
and then repatriated back to their
families so there are other teams parts
of our search team which i was part of
they were down
retrieving the deceased and all the body
parts
and they were then coming to us to be
processed and we would have to work on
them to
um
identify them basically and that must
have been presumably
it was very unpleasant and very
difficult because people were well you
just said that you had body parts and
yeah i mean some people have been
unfortunately down on the the sites
for a number of days and if you remember
it was extremely hot so remember
remember decomposition was quite rapid
um on top of the blast injuries um it
wasn't
the best environment to work in and
having dealt with
dare i say unfortunately plenty of
fatalities leading up to that fire
suicide on the railway
this was a whole new thing but yeah it
was uh it was unpleasant but there was
one
there was a case that knocked you
sideways though wasn't it can you tell
me about that um
so
when we started to be able to formally
identify the victims
we were able to set up
a temporary a temporary place of rest
where families
could come and view their loved ones
we'd let the families
pay their respects and i would go back
in
and sort of place the flowers and and
bereavement cards and stuff into the
body bags and take them back but uh
on this specific day
one of the multi-assistants just at the
blue called me serge and everyone was on
first name on nickname terms it was you
know there was no rank structure there
at all
and she's just oh this is really
unpleasant it was like well they've all
been unpleasant
and allegedly
the gentleman that was coming to view
this young chap
he had just recently lost his wife
and that was apparently his only child
so
when it came to do the they would say
put the flowers and the cards in the in
the body bag
um bearing in mind i've just got a new
baby boy
you okay
what was her
written on his card
and it just uh
just blew me away um
the feeling of guilt i had
for this poor um
chat
um when i was going home to my new
babies or my new baby my other two
little boys
and it just it's been ingrained in my
head for that day since now i just
haven't been able to um
get rid of it
do you need to do on top that's fine
you're okay
um
i'm so sorry that's
it was just part of the job but you had
a you had i guess the thing
you're saying is
it hit you in the sense that
it became a father and a son
you obviously traumatized but i can see
it's still
it still hits you even
even now that the kind of what was
written on the card and that that parent
um
and then afterwards could you tell us a
bit about
kind of what happened to you afterwards
that you started drinking yeah you were
suffering with anger yeah you know the
last thing i wanted to do is do what
i've just done shed a tear and showed to
my colleagues i was weak and
and in my head
i didn't want people to think any
different i dealt with it um
by drinking um
i noticed a drink to stop the nightmares
and the flashbacks
and it just become a revolving will it
came to a head in 2012 didn't it you
came home from a shift at the olympics
yeah you went to your shops with one of
your boys yeah but then what happened
gary so basically an incident started
developing and i was left in a situation
where i called a job in
um i had my boy with me um he was a
um
so he would have been nearly
nearly 12 right yeah and it was a
difficult situation and this matter
developed really quickly
um i called the police um and before i
knew it i was
sort of fighting with this individual
down on my local um train station they
tried to flee the sea yeah you chased
them
a uniformed officers turned up um and
they ran away into the station he was
trying to get across the tracks um
and in between that time he
was trying to be restrained by the two
uniform officers um we've gone past the
trespass gate
and it was just
going the wrong way and
for a moment
it looked like he was trying to push two
young cops onto the live track
and end up having to cross the trespass
point
tried to grapple with a fella he tried
to bite me um i punched him
to subdue him to get handcuffs on him
um
we managed to get that done but all i
could see in my head
was that young fella in a multitude i
was so fearful for not only what was
going on to me
but
to the two cops and the guy ended up
being a complainant and it it it calmed
down a point um and it took five uniform
officers to get this individual
locked up and escort without the station
and then
you know
i don't have to give a statement and
nothing really else happened um
but a few months later i was informed
that a professional standards department
wanted to talk to me about an incident
and then the matter just progressed
right and i was summonsed um to
magistrates called for an abh offense
right and what because the
the guard put complaining yeah he'd
complained yeah and in 2013
we went to to crown
um
and basically the
the job went against me um even though
the crown called judge had guided the
jury twice to inaugurate verdict
and if it wasn't for the judge
i would have gone to prison
right um he wanted pre-settings and
reports because
he wanted to know why i'd acted so out
of character so you explained what had
absolutely and then he was lenient on
you yeah
but you lost your badge yeah i had to
resign had to resign um
and then things just sort of went really
downhill quite quickly
how did you feel did you feel ashamed oh
goodness mate
the descriptive is just never-ending i'm
ashamed
i felt so
full of remorse for my family i'd let
everyone down
i just felt awful i honestly believed i
was going to prison you know thankfully
that never happened yeah
but again i think that was a
they would say the last crew and they
lived for me i just
i came back from court
and the following day i just got him in
car and
i went to a place where i used to deal
with a lot of fatalities um
and i was gonna do the same so what you
you nearly took your own life yeah i
just sort of sat in the embankment
knowing that i was on the right bit of
the track for the fast trains um
and i could see the train coming um and
i just
i don't know for a
it's a really weird thing to say and
explain but i just felt so calm and i
felt really quite happy i hadn't felt
that happy for a long time at peace yeah
just knowing that i was about to stop
being an embarrassment to everyone
having everyone down um
and the miserable calls my family as a
result of my behaviour
i was never violent to them i was just
always so angry
and
the train was nearly upon me and i just
sort of stood up and all i had to do was
take half a post forward and that would
have been that
but thankfully
i fell back down again um and train went
past
had a bit of a cry and got back in the
car when i told your wife solved the
wife um
and it was just sort of like you know
you have that moment where you just
think well
that could have been
you know
that is a
that is a hard story and that is a hard
story to tell so thank you for
it's just um
it's not something that i ever thought i
would ever
say to anyone honestly because it's just
not me it's a very brave thing um
that happened and that was the beginning
the the low point was the beginning of
your recovery you went and sought help
for post-traumatic stress disorder yeah
yeah i had some treatment um and sort of
started getting myself
back together but lots of other things
were sort of coming into me
in mind at the time then it was
reflective
in in the sense that
well i never received any help at all
but i never asked for any help so
it's a bit of a dual thing
and
you actually turned this awful situation
for yourself
into something that's very positive for
you and other people because you've set
up an organization
that helps that aims to support
emergency workers that might not be
getting the support and the support you
say you need you need will you not say
you clearly need it
myself and the other co-founder he's a
former soldier as well
um we just got ours together um and
thought well you know what let's get
something moving and we started off as
really as a
social media
but that just grew legs so quickly
because the amount of offices up and
down the country not just central to to
london
who saw our little social media bits and
pieces
and were
were telling us
almost similar stories to my own
and and i'm a lot worse um
and it just got to the point where we
thought well we're gonna have to get
these people help because they clearly
didn't have trust
in the organizations they were working
for and we was like well we get some
clinicians who are trauma-focused
therapists
and somehow we will find some funding
to help pay
because it's not cheap unfortunately to
get these people back on on their feet
to a point
but i mean
the last few years have been really hard
on emergency workers haven't they it's
been shocking you think back we had the
grenfell fire yeah the london bridge
uh events and just snowballed pandemic
pandemic the croydon thing the train but
the pandemic again it's
again
people tend to disassociate
that the person who's dealing with that
trauma
is a human being
you know they just look at the uniform
and it's the
anticipation that it's that thing well
that's their job that's what they do
but you know when these guys get home
and the girls
and they take off their uniform
irrespective of what part the services
they're in
they're human beings they've got
feelings and they've been dealing with
the most awful stuff your message to
government then would be
that there needs to be more mental
health support absolutely frontline
workers absolutely and it needs to be
done
uh an early stage let's let's get this
awareness um training
into recruits let's make it an annual
event you know you have
refresher first aid courses you have
officer safety training courses each
year let's make this part now
the awareness program that we've got
it highlights the individuals
look out for the signs and symptoms not
necessarily in themselves but it might
be in a colleague might be in a family
member thank you for coming
to talk and tell your story and i'm sure
people watching this it actually will
help them
and also your organization is helping
people as well so thanks i know it's not
easy
uh to talk about what you went through
but i'm sure it will help people
watching so thank you very much
appreciate it cheers